ورفضت أوكرانيا ذلك ووصفته بأنه محاولة مثيرة للشفقة
للانتقام من
القصف الروسي لمدينة
أوديسا الساحلية بطائرات بدون طيار
وصواريخ بعيدة المدى، كما قُتل اثنان من عمال المستودعات، وتم
تحطيم فندق مهجور
فيما كان يمكن أن يكون هجومًا روتينيًا تقريبًا
من قبل روسيا ولكن لهذا
كييف الآن.  تزعم أوكرانيا أنها قتلت
قائد أسطول البحر الأسود الروسي
الأدميرال فيكتور سوكولوف،
وتقول أوكرانيا إنها قتلت أيضًا 33
ضابطًا روسيًا آخرين في الهجوم الصاروخي
على مقر الأسطول في
سيباستوبول يوم الجمعة،
واستهدف الأوكرانيون
ضباطًا روسًا كبارًا طوال هذه الحرب
غالبًا باستخدام معلومات استخباراتية من الناتو.  وقد
كلفت كييف وحدات متخصصة
بارتكاب عمليات القتل هذه،
وهي تهدف إلى إضعاف الروح المعنوية وتقويض
أنظمة القيادة.
ليس لدى CNN تأكيد مستقل
لادعاء أوكرانيا بقتل
الأدميرال الروسي، لكن هذا سيكون أكبر
نجاح لها في هذه الحملة
وجزء من حملة مستمرة.  الجهود المبذولة
لاختراق خطوط الدفاع الروسية
لضرب شبه جزيرة القرم في نهاية المطاف،
تضمنت هجمات سابقة على بحرية بوتين
وجسرًا إلى روسيا نفسها،
وقد وصلت الآن أيضًا الدفعة الأولى من دبابات أبرامز التي تبرعت بها الولايات المتحدة إلى أوكرانيا،
لكنها ليست الأسلحة الاستراتيجية التي
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم بحاجة إلى
حزم دفاعية من الولايات المتحدة
تشمل قذائف مدفعية ضرورية،
وذخائر المريخ العالية، وصواريخ الدفاع الجوي،
وأنظمة دفاع جوي إضافية،
ومركبات تكتيكية وبعض الأنواع الأخرى من الأسلحة
التي ستثبت نفسها في
ساحة المعركة بمجرد إطلاق هذه الهجمات
[تصفيق]
بعيدة المدى  أنظمة الصواريخ للهجوم
عميقًا خلف الخطوط الروسية لقتل المزيد من
الضباط وتدمير المراكز اللوجستية.
لم تعلن الولايات المتحدة بعد أن أوكرانيا
ستحصل على هذه الصواريخ قبل أن
يتجمد الشتاء فوق الخطوط الأمامية
حيث هم
سام كايلي سي إن إن